we felt like we've been banging our head
against a brick wall for quite a long
time because fever don't take any notice
but we we did an undercover
investigation into into the corrupt
practices before the ballots for the
2022 and 2018 World Cups and that
exposed that the way to win a World Cup
to become the host of a World Cup was he
had to pay part bribes and we've gone on
since then
last summer we got an absolutely huge
tranche of documents emails dock
documents all sorts of interesting
allegations came out of that and what we
were able to construct from all of that
was was it was a clear picture of how a
man called Muhammad bin Hammam who was
Qatar's top football official had paid
bribes and plotted to bring the World
Cup to Qatar so that's the 2018 World
Cup bid or of course the 2022 World Cup
bidding placated as well going back as
far as 2010 could it possibly go back
further the US authorities have been
saying this is two generations of soccer
officials involved in this corruption
yeah sorry I think the Qatar is 2022 and
Russia went to 2018 yeah absolutely they
one of the things that we've just
written a book the ugly game the Qatari
plot to buy the World Cup and in it we
extensively research past World Cups as
well and and throughout the book it's
amazing the number of allegations that
have been over the years about how World
Cups have been one through nefarious
practices and in fact you know when we
did our undercover work those are there
was a lot of information on the on our
undercover tapes which suggested that
that previous World Cups have been won
and failed fairly with bribes and we
handed all that to FIFA and they didn't
investigate and gelatin perhaps you can
explain to us how the man at the very
top set Blatter the man who's in charge
of this organisation described as
systemic and deep rooted in its
corruption remains untouched and set to
enter a fifth term as president
well it's quite extraordinary it
continues really given that he's
presided over this complete mess but
it's a simple it's a simple form formula
there are 209 football Federation's
around the world they each get one vote
150 of them are financially dependent on
FIFA and if you want to win their votes
what you say to them is I'm going to
double your fees next next time I'm
elected and he's done that very
successfully over the years and and
they're they're incredibly grateful to
him for doing that so despite all this
if the elections do go ahead on Friday
do you think they'll still be strong
support for Sepp Blatter to stay on as
president I would imagine would be yes
because he's very very strong in Africa
and there is strong asian support and he
also has a lot of support in the
Caribbean and that's enough to carry him
home given what you've uncovered at the
Sunday Times and given what we've seen
today developing in this story where do
you think this investigation is going a
US authorities saying this is just the
beginning not the end and years to come
do you think this will be seen as the
day that changed football well it does
feel a little like the dams opening now
and that the Americans have actually
made a significant breakthrough and I
think one of the big breakthrough
breakthroughs is to be get to get one of
the sort of the FIFA stalwarts one of
the sort of the man at the top table a
man called Chuck blazer who's the top
American football official and they've
turned him and he's somebody who's who's
lived in this world seen all the bribes
for something like I'd say around about
sort of 16 years in FIFA's top table and
and for him to be talking to them and
going as far as wearing a wire and going
around and secretly recording all his
fellow FIFA executive members is quite
incredible so they've probably got quite
a lot of information there I would have
thought a Kate Johnson Calvet from The
Sunday Times this story is only just
beginning thank you very much for
joining us here on Scottie tonight thank
you